today I'm going to start off with some
background about what's going on with
economies in Asia and from that point
we'll then move into patterns of
entrepreneurship in Asia so if you look
at the largest five economies of the
world the u.s. is still the world's
single largest economy if you included
the European Union as a single economy
they would come in number two but next
to the u.s. in terms of individual you
know countries is the People's Republic
of China then India then Japan and then
West Germany so what you see here that
it's kind of interesting i'd like to
point out watch the growth rates this is
all purchase power parity calculation
and i'm going to give you two different
views of PPP calculation one by the CIA
world factbook which is this one and the
other by the World Bank because they'll
be differing by a few trillion dollars
and anyway notice that the growth rate
for the world economy went down from
three point eight percent to two point
eight percent in 2013 it's supposedly
going back up to about three or three
and a half percent historically for the
last 50 years it's been about three
point six percent a year so we're still
kind of coming starting to come out of a
downturn with regard to the United
States and Japan and West Germany we're
below the world growth rate but we're
also considerably higher than the world
average in per capita GDP which is
basically income right notice that China
and India are both considerably above
the world growth rate but their per
capita GDP is lower than the world
average that's not unusual you tend to
see economies that their growth rate
slows as the economy gets bigger so this
is what the CIA tells you 4recent
growth rates recent size of the world
economy us 16 trillion dollars China 13
trillion dollars as of 2013 now if you
look at that with what the world bank
gives you you see that the World Bank's
calculation puts China up at sixteen
trillion dollars in 2013 three trillion
right give or take a little bit but
notice this is what people are all
excited about with China right this is
the amazing growth rate over the last
really ever since done shopping and what
we've had for the last couple of years
since 2013 is a marked slow down the
growth rate and the China economy was
close to ten percent a year every year
and then beginning in 2013 2014 it has
dropped down to around seven percent and
so that's one thing to watch out for now
to really look at Asia we should look at
the other ten Asian economies that fit
into the largest 50 economies in the
world I'm leaving out Middle East
countries in this but there are really
ten other Asian economies that fit into
the top 50 conveniently South Korea in
the year 2013 exactly matched to the
world growth rate so that's why it's
green okay everything else is either if
it's in blue is faster than the world
growth rate or it's lower than the world
growth rate now this is back to CIA
world factbook figures notice the size
of the Indonesian economy Indonesia and
South Korea are the only two other Asia
economies that are already
trillion-dollar economies and CIA
conservatively estimates Indonesia to be
1.3 trillion dollars in size the World
Bank however
gives you a much more aggressive I I
guess you could call it aggressive
calculation of indonesia's of gdp which
is really 2.3 2.4 trillion dollars so
look at Indonesia nobody talks about
Indonesia right and yet Indonesia has
had a steady growth rate for the last
ten years and it's a much bigger economy
than just about anybody else what South
Korea's is you know what 1.6 trillion
1.7 trillion there are more than 100
million people in Indonesia right if you
go back to the CIA figures you see that
the average per person gross domestic
product in Indonesia is five thousand
two hundred dollars whereas you have a
much higher number in south korea in
taiwan in general the places that have
higher than world average per person gdp
will have lower growth rates so in more
recent years the world is trying to pick
up we're seeing this in the US and you
are i do want to mention just some
special situations before we move on
first of all there have been some
incidents that have been bad enough to
have noticeable direct impact on the
size of economy the economic growth
rates one is the big earthquake and
tsunami in japan one was the floods and
thailand the coup in thailand or the
worry about the coup in thailand last
year was already starting to have an
impact on their growth rate germany has
been real low growth rate for the last
few years but that's actually not that
unusual ever since the country reunified
around 0.9 one percent growth has really
been what Germany has had for the last
20 or 30 years it really picked up after
the 2008 Lehman shock Germany picked up
and had
% growth rate one other thing that's
worth noting is the drop in oil prices
last year really hit exporting economies
um bat export oil so that's been an
issue now if you look a little bit more
specifically you see that um there's a
big trend among what I would call the
jumping-off points to China and this has
to do with concern over what would
happen in China as the economy slows
down so back in 2010 Singapore had like
a fifteen percent a year growth rate and
it dropped like a rock down to one or
two percent depending on whether you're
you know how you're calculating the
growth rate of the economy 2002 dollars
2003 dollars and Taiwan also had a drop
from ten percent down to one point
whatever percent inside the People's
Republic of China itself there was a
forty-four percent drop in venture
capital investments in 2012 so everybody
slows down waits watches what's going to
happen and so now you're starting to see
the uptick again now you're starting to
see more confidence in how China is
going to manage its economic slowdown
especially Hong Kong has been very
aggressive in establishing itself as a
convenient place to do China business
the liberalisation of the be so
that you can trade actively renminbi in
Hong Kong is trying to have an impact
Singapore has also been very
aggressively doing its own investments
in advanced technology the government of
Singapore has some major programs in
biotech in other kinds of areas that are
allowing it to keep a relatively
aggressive growth rate and one reason
for the slow down as bad as it is in
South Korea and Singapore has been you
know the general slowdown in Europe it's
harder to sell there
oh so that's one thing that you notice
in these trends the final thing that I'd
like to point about general trends is
that Southeast Asia and South East and
South Asia are growing steadily and
doing very actually much more exciting
than you would think about from what you
hear on the news you don't hear about
them nearly as much on the news as you
might think partly the lower cost
economies in Southeast Asia are becoming
low-cost alternatives to China but cause
in China the east coast cities are
getting to be very expensive the average
gdp per person across people's republic
of china was about nine thousand eight
hundred dollars the average per person
in the Big East Coast cities is more
like nineteen thousand dollars so
they're really it's you know where do
you go do you go to the interior of
China or do you go down to the yet Nam
or do you go down to one of the other
Southeast Asian countries in order to
set up your Asia outpost the domestic
market growth has really been what's
been fueling the Southeast Asian
economies some of it is still what I
would call developing economy of
phenomena namely infrastructure rollout
Thailand is building a big railway
system right now and so this kind of
thing you know is spending that really
does help push growth along China's
engine of growth a few years ago shifted
away from infrastructure build-out to
being consumer driven so the real
industry sectors that are growing fast
in China now really have much more to do
with consumer spending India the World
Bank at least is very positive that
India is coming back up to around six
and a half percent growth and another
country that deserves special mention is
the Philippines people don't talk much
about the Philippines but it's actually
got a very robust software industry and
it's doing a lot of business process
outsourcing
that's kind of where we are in terms of
where the economies in Asia are what
does this mean for entrepreneurship okay
I'm going to present material from the
Global Entrepreneurship monitor for the
next few slides this is a huge survey
that's done every year they survey about
200,000 people in over 90 countries and
come up with rates of entrepreneurship
and attitude toward entrepreneurship in
these different countries each country
has its own team but they have a very
tight control in the central
organization that if the individual
country teams do not show sufficient
care and how they collect their data
they don't report the data from the
country that year and we'll see some
gaps in what we look at one of the
things that they have done is they have
given us the tier 8 which is very nice
for Asia but what it stands for is total
early-stage entrepreneurial activity and
essentially how they define tier 8 look
at this process you've got a potential
entrepreneur that's not included in the
tier 8 but when that person starts to be
involved in actually setting up a
business or if they are running a
business that is less than 3.5 years old
meaning it's paid a salary to somebody
for up to three and a half years they
fit into this definition of the tier 8 I
kind of like this a graph because either
they stay running the company or the
businesses discontinued it may be bought
by another business that may fail
something may happen and if that happens
then this person may come back and
become a potential entrepreneur again
keep that point in mind because the
valley works very much on this continual
flow of people from project project
right so the tier 8 in the United States
over the last 02 / 13 years
has risen to 13.8 percent this is
actually quite robust for an economy
that's as advanced as the United States
is think about the alternatives to being
an entrepreneur generally people don't
become an entrepreneur in the United
States because they have to whereas in
other economies you may become an
entrepreneur if there are no salary jobs
that you can apply for there's a
noticeable drop in the rate of
entrepreneurs in the population around
2010 everybody gets conservative after
an economic downturn now they didn't get
as nearly as conservative as the
investors did there were probably a lot
of people who wanted to be entrepreneurs
but to actually be setting up a company
or you know you kind of got to have some
money so that's the US there's our
baseline there are about five or six
five six one two three four five five
asian economies that have higher tier
eights than the United States does first
of all look at the volatility I'm amazed
at the situation in China where you go
from twenty four percent to thirteen
percent and then back up to fifteen
point five percent the situation in
Indonesia looks like a really high rate
in the year 2013 and then it dropped to
just above the American rate in 2014 on
the yeah the situation in Thailand
looked relatively uninteresting eighteen
fifteen percent but then it jumped up
last year it was twenty-three percent of
all of the people between 18 and 64
years old who are either starting a
company or running a company that's
Leslie and a three and a half years old
so this is a kind of trend that you see
so five countries with a higher tier
eight and six countries or so with a
lower tier eight than the US the
volatility is remarkable here too so
this is India way back in 2002 India had
a 16-percent tier 8 and then dropped to
ten eleven percent then Global
Entrepreneurship monitor would not
accept their reports for a few years
they showed up again in 2013 with a nine
point nine percent rate and then a six
point six percent rate the next one down
is Singapore which has gone from down
and six percent four point eight percent
and then has jumped back up to eleven
percent Taiwan with an eight point five
percent rate has been relatively steady
for the years that they've looked at it
South Korea um has rooted South Korea go
south korea's this one they didn't take
South Korea's numbers in 2014 so South
Korea has had this relatively stable
rate at seven or eight percent and
Malaysia dropped like a rock from 2006
to 2009 and then has stayed around six
percent and the low people on the totem
pole is Japan right three-point-eight
percent so what's going on the first
thing you can see is that the countries
with a higher tier eight than the United
States all have relatively low GDP per
person right they're all still
relatively developing economies so
that's not surprising the countries with
a lower tier eight than the US are kind
of harder to figure out I frankly was
very surprised to find the relatively
low tier eight in India that just
doesn't make sense because you would
think that there would be an awful lot
of people who had to be entrepreneurial
in a rapidly urbanizing and rapid
developing economy similarly I felt that
way about Malaysia as well with Japan
especially yeah that's got everybody
talks bad about Japan but Japan's tea
rate is so low and Japanese
entrepreneurs have you know such a
terrible idea about there not being
opportunities for entrepreneurs we'll
come to that in a few minutes but you
would have expected somewhat of a higher
rate Global Entrepreneurship monitor has
taken this general trend of how many
entrepreneurs you have in an economy
along with the stage of economic
development and they've given you a very
nice smiley face graph out of it we're
at lower GDP per person you get a lot
higher rates of entrepreneurship in the
economy so China that year was sixteen
percent CN Japan is down here even below
the rate UK is there Netherlands is
there Hong Kong was a high rate that
year and the US was quite high rate I'll
above the world average what's going on
according to their analysis you have
three stages of economic development in
the three stages of economic development
one is what they call factor driven
that's a developing economy the second
stage is really efficiency driven after
an economy has developed domestically
some of the companies that grow large
during that first stage will globalize
that tends to be an efficiency driven
economy because those big companies
control a lot of capital they have the
most prestigious jobs people want to
work there those kinds of countries
typically have a low tier 8 then you see
a somewhat increase in the tier 8 in an
economy as the per person GDP continues
to grow higher and this is because a lot
of people are not satisfied with a job
in a big company they think they can do
better for them
in a more advanced economy so there's a
lot of social things that go on in this
sweep of development first of all it is
true that at this stage typically there
are fewer big companies you could work
at so the chances are that you're going
to have to be an entrepreneur is higher
at this stage though a lot of the people
who work for big companies their
children don't want to do what their
parents did and the parents would like
to see the children have better
opportunities and they did so a lot of
it has to do with the spread of
education through the economy it has to
do with the skills that are demanded of
people who have college education you
can get a great job working in a factory
with a high school education but if
you've got a college education you
typically want something better so they
g.e.m also has this kind of thing I want
you to look at the percentages according
to them in a factor driven economy about
thirty percent of the people who are
involved in NT activities are that way
because of necessity and almost fifty
percent are that way because of seeking
better opportunities for themselves in
the efficiency driven economy about
thirty percent a little bit lower
somewhere around forty-six forty-seven
percent and then in the innovation
driven economies you really see people
after the opportunity alright that's
what they published I went back into
their data and took a look at it and all
of the Asia economies were looking at
our incredibly opportunity driven now
this is reported by the people who took
the survey so maybe they didn't want to
admit that they had to become an
entrepreneur okay there you got to
recognize that there's that possibility
in the survey but the ratio of
opportunity driven people even in the
factor driven economies is over
fifty-eight percent right fifty-six
fifty-seven percent is the lowest and
you get you know up in the seventy or
eighty percent range for quite a lot of
of the people there in what they group
as efficiency driven economies the ratio
is still that high and of course in the
the the advanced economies it's also
very high ratio of people who are driven
by opportunity so that's um not that
different between Asia and the United
States and if you think about it the
process of starting a company may be
relatively easier or harder in a
particular economy but the similarities
are much greater between Asia in the US
on the creation side than it is at the
growth and exit side it's a growth in
exit where you really see differences
between these different economies let's
take a couple of minutes and look at
Silicon Valley as a baseline one of our
speakers this quarter talked about how
many companies are are in Silicon Valley
and how everybody is involved in
starting a company in Silicon Valley
right I ran into this very interesting
graph which is great because you can't
see any pattern essentially Silicon
Valley is one of these lines and the
dotted line is the average of innovation
centers urban innovation centers in the
United States but if you want to know
who really had more startup companies
per hundred thousand people in the
population it was orlando florida okay
so yep published results and so I think
that yeah right now I wonder if
Cinderella does count in that anyway how
innovation centers look like innovation
centers it's very similar here than it
is in other places inside the United
States so what makes Silicon Valley
different we've got our famous
entrepreneurs
but the reason our entrepreneurs are
famous is because every seven or eight
years Silicon Valley will be dead center
in the middle of a major new wave of
Industry a major new industry will
appear often based on some disruptive
innovation and the point is we will have
one or two companies that become world
leading multi-billion dollar companies
out of this phenomenon if you really
look more recently and do a more
detailed analysis from the early 2000s
on down you've got the web 2.0 era in
the early 2000s and you've got social
networking built on social networking
you've got big data analytics built on
big data analytics as new types of big
data IOT is on the horizon so you really
see companies that are coming out of
each one of these cloud computing fits
in there right cloudera that's what
Silicon Valley is famous for and this is
one thing that you haven't seen in Asia
yet except for maybe Alibaba so I wonder
if with Alibaba and Tencent and these
companies from China that are really
shaking up the world you're seeing the
same thing but delayed by 10 years right
so that's kind of an interesting pattern
if you go a little bit further how
companies are started up in order to
start a company it takes people it takes
an idea and it takes a little bit of
cash take some money so what you have to
have in order to create a company to
have a system and an entrepreneurial
ecosystem you have to have sources for
those three elements you do need an
infrastructure but you also have to have
the right kind of dynamics that sort of
encourage them to move into a new
combination so this means that if you
want to compare entrepreneurial
ecosystems on the people
the people that found companies yes you
do look at the demographics they may
differ not only in terms of age in terms
of gender in turn but also in terms of
the background expertise are more
entrepreneurs technical or more of them
coming out of the business environment
you do have sources of the team can be
either existing companies or
universities or it could be founding
entrepreneurs going back and becoming a
serial entrepreneur you've got the
dynamics for that really have to do with
the mobility of the labor market and
that in turn involves a lot of factors
such as the social attractiveness of
being an entrepreneur one time I was
addressing a group of asian students
about entrepreneurship and so I asked
why do you want to be entrepreneurs I
got this blank stare and finally one
young woman from South Korea said for
the good of society and I thought okay I
wonder how many people at Stanford would
have answered that question that way
anyway the career cost of failure is a
dynamic that will either keep you in
your current job or encourage you to
start a new job on the idea side you've
got the sources of the ideas what you're
really looking at is perception
entrepreneurs do what they do because
they think they have a market
opportunity and they think they can
access that market opportunity so that
is very highly indicated on perception
you get a lot of stuff from Global
Entrepreneurship monitor about these
attitudes that I'm not going to share
today you can look at their report it is
quite interesting own tech transfer
knowledge transfer is a big part of how
the ideas come into being sources of
capital cost of capital conditions for
capital one of the big issues and a lot
of Asian economies is the issue of
personal guarantees there's a lot of
debt financing outside Silicon Valley
and you go to a bank and you take out a
loan to start a company and you must
Sign personal guarantee for that loan to
your startup company meaning if the
startup company doesn't do well they
take your house right and I do have to
say this is not only in Asia I got
burned that way in Georgia so I know
what that's like anyway with then you do
have this kind of other category of
infrastructure which is the legal system
whether case law is interpreted
consistently or not the whole existence
of mentors who are not really part of
the company but who are good personal
advisors to the entrepreneurs you know
the whole issues with corruption is
basically an infrastructure issue that a
company has to deal with if you're
really going to do a thorough comparison
across countries you have to look at all
of these elements of the system yeah
we'll come back to this but notice that
the founding team really is key at this
stage because they will be the sort of
direct source of the idea and they will
be the direct source of the first
capital they possibly after hitting up
their family for some extra cash will be
the first source of capital for the
company so that is pretty universal
where you really get a difference is in
the patterns of growth if you look at a
startup company it will go through three
distinct stages of growth the first
stage is really this idea stage the
second stage is a prototype stage and
then the third stage is the product
stage so what you see in Silicon Valley
is as rapid growth as quickly as
possible with the idea that eventually
once you've got a product out in the
market and your company is well valued
your
going to exit and you will exit in one
of two ways you will either be bought by
a big company or you'll go IPO on the
public market so what you see is a
gradual shift from the founders who
owned almost all of the company at this
stage to the venture capitalists and
others who really own the majority of
the company by the time it goes IPO most
American companies at the time of IPO
will have an ownership structure that's
basically before the public stock is
sold off maybe the founders will have
ten or twenty percent the venture
capitalists will have the biggest share
which may account for why a lot of times
founders are no longer running their own
companies and then they'll sell you know
a third or a half of the available stock
in the company on the public market in
Asia you get a pattern where most
entrepreneurs hold on too much larger
shares of their company so that even
after the company sold on the public
stock is sold on the public exchange a
single person alone fifty percent or
more of the company it's kind of like a
public company but yet it's not and so
you do get drastic changes if you really
compare what you have to look at you do
have to look at the accessibility of
workers separate from the entrepreneurs
this is something nobody talks about
when they describe Silicon Valley we're
such a wonderful place of entrepreneurs
the vast majority of people in Silicon
Valley are not in the process of
starting a company now but you sure have
a lot of people working at company's
growing a hundred percent a year rapid
growth companies you know do you want to
call palantir a start-up do you want to
call
you can't call Google a start-up anymore
but you have people who are accessible
in new companies that are establishing
their own prestige you also have on the
people side attitudes of manager
investor relations so I mentioned the
investors who will get rid of the
founder manager of the company and put
in a professional manager who has
industry experience or something oh you
have a churn rate that here involves not
only the workers and the founders but
whether they see it as a good thing to
stay in a company for two or three years
and then jump up to a better job in
another company with regard to the ideas
you do have facilities for prototyping
and and also I think the biggest thing
about the idea side if you're comparing
companies when the idea is now a product
then the real issue is market access and
you need to look at that not only in
consumer markets but also when you need
b2b kinds of activities even channel
sales for a consumer product capital
you've got you know the sources and the
conditions for funding you've got
patterns evaluation that you can compare
you can compare the changes of ownership
and then finally you can compare the
different kind of exit patterns so
here's a case example here's a case
study from Silicon Valley that I think
is classic Silicon Valley in many ways
so square square really started in 2009
or sometime around 2008-2009 why did it
start Jack Dorsey had been fired from
the board of Twitter he was CEO of
Twitter and the investors decided they
needed somebody else Jack had a lot of
money Jack had some time so he got
together with some other people and
founded this cry
a little company square we don't know
how much of his own money he put into it
the first time they showed up on in the
news was in November of 2009 raising
their series a venture capital money 10
million that was a big valuation in 2009
right remember 2008 had happened and
investors were not investing in anything
and they managed to get 10 million
dollars in their first round okay that's
pretty impressive the other impressive
thing is they started their service
within six months as fast as you can go
right is the general speed in Silicon
Valley and as soon as I started their
service I started getting revenue but
that meant that they're just going to
get their next round of venture capital
as quickly as they can about 13 months
after their first round of venture
capital then they by this point the news
reports that they had processed about a
billion dollars of payments if you
figure how much money they keep it's
generally around one percent because
they have to pay the credit card fees
out of their two point seven five
percent commission so if you figure that
they had it they processed a billion
dollars of payments they probably had
about 10 million dollars of revenue that
year but you don't sit back and just say
wonderful we're a profitable company you
go out and raise another hundred three
million dollars they actually did this
in two rounds one round of a hundred
million but they let Richard Branson
invest three million dollars later they
were very patient with him and they
called it Series C but it was six months
later December of 2011 by this point
they've got 150 people they're paying on
this all right this is one reason you
have to grow as fast as you can by 2012
they were four times as big so eight
billion 80 million dollars in revenue
somewhere around that so they raised two
hundred million dollars at this point
square is growing so fast that they had
a market cap that was they had a
valuation that was probably somewhere in
the neighborhood of ten billion
if anybody wanted to buy square in 2012
early 2013 they would have probably had
to pay at least ten billion dollars for
square whereas things got kind of not so
good they had to around a debt financing
in 2013 they also just raised 150
million dollars of series ii venture
capital last year last fall 2014 and so
so far they have raised almost six
hundred million dollars of funds from
investors at the same time they probably
have revenue of about five hundred
million dollars out of 30 billion
dollars of credit card payments that
they've processed why do you keep
raising money first of all they did
Chuck they did talk to people about
going IPO in 2014 and the discussions
did not go so well because it was
looking like their business was starting
to be squeezed by some other groups
other people does the word Ally pay mean
things to people so you know square may
get squeezed in the world market but
they are growing as fast as they can in
terms of numbers of people and they are
definitely thinking about maximizing the
valuation of the company at the time of
exit that is a Silicon Valley attitude
that is not necessarily shared in other
places if you look at how the investors
see exits the venture capital industry
in the United States has gotten real
clever after about the year 2000 they've
decided that you can do a better
businesses of entry capitalists by
growing your company for merger and
acquisition rather than by relying on
IPO so now we have about nine ma exits
for every single IPO exit in the United
States in Silicon Valley the number is
about half of the
of the United States in 2012 there were
two hundred and ten ma exits from
Silicon Valley and less than 20 IPOs out
of Silicon Valley so it's interesting
how this has become what's really going
on in our system there's one other thing
that we need to look at in terms of
understanding why entrepreneurship works
differently in Asia and that is that
American big companies are looking for
disruptive ideas from startup companies
on the outside so I those of you who've
heard me give this talk a number of
times know that I've got a case study of
Google about this right so we looked at
Google and in the year 2011 Google's
internal research and development
activities accounted for 6.2 billion
dollars that was 13.1 percent of
Google's revenues that year and it
really average for software industries
is 13.3 percent so that's pretty normal
but that year google paid 12.5 billion
dollars for motorola mobility they
wanted what Motorola Mobility had right
then the patent portfolio that Motorola
had was essential to their android phone
right then that's why you spend twice as
much as your total R&D budget buying it
last year google bought nest for four
billion dollars when you see a major
acquisition like that it's either a
repositioning of the company for
strategy sake but whatever it is it's a
business decision for the market right
then in 2011 google also bought 24
startup companies after 2011 they start
making these they stopped making these
reports it became harder to figure find
this stuff out we estimated that they
spent about seven hundred million
dollars buying startup companies in 2011
about half of the instances were
actually listed and the other half you
kind of figured out how much people how
many people the startup company had and
all this other kind of indirect evidence
ten or fifteen percent of their company
internal R&D budget the equivalent of
that amount would go into buying ideas
from the outside they're not going to
buy something that will be a net loss on
their books for more than a year or so
so typically you see companies buying up
other companies really within a year of
whatever this startup company has going
to market their buying not just the
technology they're buying the people and
the market knowledge the business
knowledge that those people also bring
in 2011 Google spent a hundred million
dollars doing corporate venture capital
investments and by our estimation Google
spent about 30 million dollars in 2011
in all externally funding funding
research at universities worldwide so
what does this mean it means that the
closer you get to market the more
expensive it is and the further away
from the market that you get the less
you are buying control over some
business activity and the more you are
paying to be part of something that
unfolds or is evolving so the situation
at Google is a real clear idea of how
the companies here in Silicon Valley
participate in the Silicon Valley
innovation system not just buying
companies and so forth but they interact
actively with startup companies they buy
products from startup companies all be
referenced customers for start-up
companies and that's a very important
function that these companies fulfill in
our system now if you start to look at
Asia I want to look at the capital first
we'll start capital and then we'll talk
people and then we'll talk ideas so
there's friends and family money
everywhere that seems to be universal
most Asian economies if there is a break
in their pipeline it's not at the VC
stage it's at the angel investor stage
between friends and family money and
venture capital money there is this
really awkward time when you really need
professional investors who have control
over hundreds of thousands of dollars
and that tends to be the gap in just
about all of the major Asian economies
venture capital is really on the up in
Asia we've got to slide some slides on
that but what you do see is you see a
lot of kind of financial industry
decision making as opposed to the
venture capitalists here who are much
more oriented to the entrepreneur side
and seeing value in crazy ideas here in
the exit patterns it's a huge difference
between Asia and the US while it's
ninety percent exit by Emma day in the
US reports that I get from investors in
Japan and in South Korea is that 85
eighty to eighty-five percent of all of
the successful exits there by
venture-backed companies is through IPO
and the size of the IPO is very
different typically companies raise much
less money in IPO in Asia and the
entrepreneur holds on to a lot more of
it so Ernst & Young does a real good
survey of worldwide venture capital
every year notice that of the venture
capital and this is not angel money this
is venture capital money the u.s.
accounted for most of it right the year
2013 and next to the US was Europe
Israel 1.7 billion dollars invested 1
point 0 billion dollars invested in
canada china accounted for 3.5 billion
dollars of venture capital investment
it's and then finally India accounted
for 1.8 billion dollars of entry capital
investments but let's look a little more
deeply at some of these selected Asia
economies in China the amount of money
that people raised that the venture
capitalists raised dropped like a rock
because of the slow down investors are
not going to put their money into
high-risk investments when you don't
know what's happening in the economy the
slowdown did not happen nearly as much
in the amount of money invested it went
from 6.1 billion in 2010 down to 3.5
billion that's okay it's a lot but it's
not as much as the drop from 22 billion
to 2 billion raised right you do see a
relatively large size of investments up
until this point and kind of shrinking
size of a round in China one thing that
I think is positive about that is that
in the old days when you see these
rounds around 10 million dollars of
money raised those are not Silicon
Valley style startups those are large
factories that people are putting
together I remember hearing that
American venture capitalists who went
over to China started investing in milk
carton factories in chocolate factories
because candy consumption in China was
going up sixty percent a year you invest
in what makes the money right the
interesting thing that happened in
regard to exits in China is that I POS
used to be by far more than M&A but for
the first time ever in the year 2013
there were more in a day exits than
there were IPO exits so China is
becoming I think more sophisticated I
don't think you need to have a nine to
one ratio like we do in the US but it's
good that there's more than na
kind of option for companies to exit at
in China than there used to be if you
look at India you see a very similar
drop like a rock in the amount of money
raised they raised five hundred million
dollars of venture capital money in 2010
and they raised 10 million 11 million
dollars of entry capital money in the
year 2013 ouch that's a huge drop but
they are continuing to invest a
relatively robust amount of money from
money that they raised years before has
to be I think you are also seeing more
angel investment money coming in from
overseas into India so it could be that
some of this 1.8 billion was really far
in venture capital that doesn't fit the
amount of VC raised by those same funds
the size of the round has also shrunk in
India which is interesting and India has
the most robust M&A kind of ratio to IPO
that we see among these countries that
we're looking at and it's relatively
been kind of consistent that way
companies are not going IPO in India and
I'm not really sure why I'm not sure if
this is something that people are
concerned about or so maybe it was you
know this was pre Modi right so it could
be that the current administration in
India is making it much more of safe
feeling to exit now in Japan you see a
real uptick from the real low rate low
downturn in the amount of venture
capital money right now this is the
amount of funds invested this is not the
amount of funds raised so somewhere
between 1.1 billion and 1.8 billion
dollars depending on how you count the
in dollar exchange rate they calculated
it 100 yen to the dollar and it's now
more like 120 but
pattern is relatively clear you see a
definite uptick in recent years I wasn't
able to get the data on exits in Japan
my sense is that ma is really picking up
but it's not the kind of open innovation
in MA that say you see with Google
buying up startup companies it really
has to do with companies that have
assets that are worth more than their
stock and so Emma day is picking up in
Japan but it's still got a ways to go in
South Korea you see a steady rise in
venture capital investing 1.1 billion
dollars u.s. I'm surprised that didn't
make it onto ernst & young's list of
large venture capital investments but
where you see the most striking rise is
singapore singapore for the last few
years not only has had a relatively
sudden jump in the number of investment
deals right 80 deals but you know 450
million dollars invested and according
to the source that of this uh graph that
accounted for fifty-eight percent of all
of the investments in ASEAN that year so
Singapore is definitely looking at
growth in in ASEAN as something that
they see themselves as competitively
advantage dat that's the patterns in
venture capital now if you look at the
patterns of people flow yeah
entrepreneurs are everywhere you will
find them in every population the real
problem is the growth stage getting
people to come to work for your company
is hard if your company is not named
Sony in Japan or if your company is not
named LG or Samsung in South Korea the
quality it's harder to get good quality
people and a startup company or a
rapidly growing company especially if
it's not your
own startup company one of the reasons
is that the startup companies are not
really offering the kind of lucrative
packages that you get here so stock
options are a noticeable part of the
compensation package here if you're
doing sales for a company you can really
make a lot of money if you exceed your
sales quota and for a rapidly growing
company there's a lot of people who are
quite happy with that kind of job one
other thing is happening in the people
function I think it was last week didn't
June our speaker from China last week
mentioned that baidu Alibaba and Tencent
are now siphoning off the good knowledge
workers so that it's harder for startup
companies to hire these people than it
used to be so you get these big
companies who become prestige companies
I give better work conditions and so
it's harder to get people to work in a
start-up um there is still a social
stigma about entrepreneurship in Asia
this is not just a fear of failure what
it is is partly a very rational economic
decision because of a very low mobility
in the labor market if you go to work in
a startup company in Asia and it doesn't
work out you can't shrug it off and be
you know talking to people to the
recruiter next week like people do here
and you do get an awful lot of family
pressure and that kind of family
pressure really rings home to me my mom
went through the depression I was a
young child and my mom went through the
American depression she still asks me
are you okay Richard the stability is a
huge you know goal for people who went
through that kind of situation and so
post-war Japan post-war Korea post
Cultural Revolution China of course the
senior people in those countries are
going to have a preference for what they
see is a better route to success a more
stable route 26
best it is a high career cost of failure
for people and what you don't see is the
successful people also don't flow back
into the system because we have such a
sense of exits here in the States the
successful entrepreneurs flow back into
the system and start another company or
they become a venture capital investor
how many people do you see who started
the company and now they're talking from
the standpoint of a VC or an angel
investor that is something that hasn't
happened in Asia yet these people would
have to sell the stock in their
companies before they could have the
kind of finances to really get into
investment like that that does not put
their knowledge back into the system
enough Oh with regard to flow of ideas
Oh entrepreneurial innovation is a very
popular topic among every government in
Asia and I've met with most of them in
the last year I think that you see this
real emphasis on tech transfer some of
its kind of scary stuff if you tell a
university that you really should be
doing innovation instead of research
what does that mean and you know it does
have a dangerous aspect if you start to
try to develop too much business from a
university that may not be the most
productive way to develop new business
mentoring is not well developed in Asia
I think that a lot of it has to do with
Confucianism that someone who is the
master should be imitated and that's
wonderful but it's a one-way flow really
the master tell it shows how things are
done but doesn't really engage in
dialogue with the apprentice so I do
think that that's an issue in Asian
economies um I think that to a certain
extent there's all
so the concern about face why don't u
niversity professors in Asia do more
aggressive consulting you don't see it
nearly as much partly because if they
say something stupid the career cost of
that failure is very high it really
hurts face oh I think that certainly if
you talk about idea flow if the idea is
a product then if it's gotten to the
product stage market access is much more
difficult in Asia than it is here
especially in the b2b sector and this
has to do with start with the big
company attitudes are not participating
in open innovation nearly as much as
they do here um and yeah I think that if
you don't have someone who's willing to
buy your idea it's much harder to get
your idea out to the public we have a
much more rapid flow here as a result so
take away points entrepreneurship in
Asia is incredibly opportunity driven
forget the stage of economic development
that's a remarkably widespread attitude
the people in Asia are still focused on
the creation stage in this whole
entrepreneurship process I think they're
not looking nearly enough at the growth
and exit stage and that also applies to
government policy and frankly speaking
it applies to the kind of research
that's being done into entrepreneurship
what's next you're still seeing a lot of
independent kind of hub-and-spoke
between Silicon Valley and individual
Asian countries so with the exception of
China and everybody's interested in
getting a piece of the growth in China
oh you know ty is going to look at the
Indian community and going to look at
investments back in southie South Asia
you've got SAV VI the strategic
association of Vietnam venture investors
that
Vietnam you've got the people who look
at Taiwan you've got the people who look
at Japan you've got the people who look
at South Korea it's very much
hub-and-spoke I have a feeling that
we're going to start to see a lot more
networking across borders in Asia and
young people who are used to hackathons
who are used to engaging each other
through online media without being next
to each other physically may actually
start to do some interesting things with
kind of more network effect so if we had
to say there's a next stage that that's
where I would kind of make a guess so
i'll call it into my prepared remarks at
that point we've got a few minutes left
for Q&A thanks for your attention and
the floor is open and the CIA have such
statements it has to do with how you
calculate the purchase power parity you
know that the idea is that you have a
basket of similar goods and services and
what can you buy for a certain amount of
money so you have the problem of
calculating that at one point in time
and if you look over a series of years
you also have the problem of are you
calculating in this year's currency or
in a previous year's currency you have
to really be careful about putting this
information together the CIA tells you
very clearly that all these numbers are
2013 numbers and the World Bank is less
clear but i think that they revised
their numbers a little bit more
frequently than the CIA does so yeah and
and that's good to remember about
economics you want to see the patterns
and the trends but you don't really want
to get too detailed about it slow down
push for stop no you can see everywhere
I and but you know it look like they
hope that every young generation start a
new company you know so the web so when
they can get a people walking by so what
what do you think about this channel
current hacia well until recently the
growth in China has been so incredibly
rapid that entrepreneurship was a
relatively safe career decision and even
the big companies in the east you know
did you want to go to work for Foxconn
or do you want to do your own thing
right if you're doing outsource work for
somebody else manufacturing that's not
that interesting a job and so I think
that it was very attractive to large
numbers of young people period now as
things are slowing down you're also
seeing large companies having a
noticeable percentage of available
capital in China and so that's a
difference that shifts things around
quite a bit and oh my sense is that
China has been such a gold rush that it
made economic sense to try to go out and
be an entrepreneur now as the east coast
slows down what's going to happen I
really wonder if it's going to continue
to shift into the tier two and Tier
three cities on the interior chengdu is
very interesting there's a lot of things
going on wuhan very interesting so
you're seeing that kind of a shift and
there's still an amazing amount of
rollout that's possible in China right
if gdp across the country is still only
nine thousand eight hundred dollars per
person what will it be you know when
they get up to 36,000 or thirty nine
thousand dollars per person
and so I think that right now the
government realizes that it really needs
to avoid some of the capital traps that
Japan and Korea fell into we're the
first generation of very successful
companies went global but they became
such powerful players in the economy
that they were able basically to kind of
push out a lot of entrepreneurial
possibilities and that led to slow
economic growth once you go global how
do you get more growth right so China is
trying to avoid that trap oh and it's
also still in the process of
straightening out it's just basic kind
of commercial infrastructure you know
how will the law be interpreted we
talked about this last week in the
session here if the crackdown on
corruption indicates a greater
consistency in the application of the
law that's great for everybody I expect
that to happen the question is how
quickly will it happen but that's a
great question Blair words gene hardware
and devices for our current versus
software services any more dominant here
partly because you know anyway that's
exactly why you don't see so much
innovation from Chinese startup
companies there's too much good business
to do without spending the time to
develop something advanced right here if
you can make a lot of money developing
an iphone app and get into the market
within a few months why in the world
would you spend the time to design a
chip and then find someplace to
fabricate it and then find some group of
people to buy it the it's where people
perceive the opportunities right now the
opportunities in the valley are
perceived in very fast fast and division
areas um and the big companies in the
valley know very well how to use the
positions to get into business lines
that really would be hard for a start-up
to start without you know an amazing
amount of resources in China the same
kind of thing applies getting to market
first with your idea is a very important
competitive thing and why sit around and
incubate some technology for two years
so you can be my earning money this year
I so I think that that's a very good
question i think hardware is not going
to disappear but i think that the
pressure on the hardware makers is to be
together with the end-users very early
on and the companies like Apple and
Google and Amazon that know how to do
this kind of system development will be
more successful than the old style
companies that only outsource what they
have designed in-house so I do think
there's a lot of future and hardware but
it's harder it's it's a more difficult
play also a good question startups
entrepreneurs places in the US you often
divide them into categories business to
the customer like business to business
or business to consumer what we divided
according to category of products or
services your such is if you look
through those eyes is there any patterns
and in the Asian entrepreneurs of a
universe services less product more
business to business alone with general
economic development you see a market
increase in the percentage of the
economy taken off I services and you
know so what does X ensure is that a
services company or a software company
services and so I think that you do see
more on the services side but it all
depends on the hardware and software
right there will always be a place for
it it's just how can you have the
dynamics to
have a good successful company I think
in the hardware area that's a harder
play than it used to be you know the old
days when the people who made the
microprocessor chips controlled the
price of the computer kind of the
opposite now okay go ahead Rick g-sync
patent law IP protection is a
significant element or not region in
motion it is but more important than
that is how the law is applied well I
think the biggest issue in China has
been that courts do not respect each
other in terms of case law so if this
Court decides a case this way some other
court may decided a totally different
way forget precedent you got to be
kidding and that has had a negative
effect just about every country in Asia
now has a good IP law a guy a good IP
law framework the problem is how they're
implemented and that I think China sees
that it has to improve the consistency
there I really do think that's part of
the corruption crackdown that's going on
now in places where corruption has been
too big a part of the economy you see a
direct negative impact on GDP growth and
China doesn't want that they want to
slow down but they want to manage it and
keep it nice and robust right so I do
think IP laws important another issue
with IP one of the things that's most
sophisticated about Silicon Valley is
knowing how much you can talk about and
knowing what kind of discussions of new
ideas you can have without violating
somebody's intellectual property even
your own companies right and we're a
very litigious society and I think part
of that is that we've all seen the
examples where so and so you know stolz
a background IP from
body and started a company with it and
in general people in the valley are
really smart about what they can say and
they talk if you don't have a real good
body of case law and how those things
are interpreted you're afraid to talk
and I think there's more fear of talking
in Asia than there is here it's it's
still a newer system great one more
question go ahead how much of Asia's
rogue that you're talking about this
more excuse the language is a copycat as
opposed to real yeah okay that's a good
question I think that if you're copying
an idea from one market into another
market that's not necessarily a bad
thing oh there are so many great
business ideas here that just you really
ought to take to Asia and there are so
many great business ideas in Asia that
you really ought to take here but the
localization is really hard okay I think
that somebody who just tried to read a
patent and copy the patent down and file
that same patent in another country
probably doesn't have what it takes to
turn that into a profitable business and
so you really do have to give credit to
that creative aspect of copying now as
you get a more advanced economy there's
more of a base inside your domestic
economy that you might infringe and
that's what people really care about so
if and what government IP law really
cares about so that you want to avoid
infringement in a more advanced economy
you really have to be engaged in more
advanced research in order to bring
something to market just because you'll
get shot otherwise right so
if you say what percentage for the last
40 years there hasn't been that much
copying in Japan for the last 15 or 20
years there hasn't been that much
copying in Korea China is still engaged
in quite a bit of robust copying not
only of overseas ideas but we had a
speaker in this series not too long ago
who pointed out that there are 1300
different versions of groupon in China
so somebody brings in an idea and
everybody's going to try to do the same
thing it's a huge country that's
expanding so rapidly you can still get
away with that stuff it won't last
forever ya te t and given it their the
stuff they have such big numbers I'm
wondering and when three verses like
this and hovered in other schools and
China and other Asian countries and they
remember the future yeah do they have a
you know grassroots roast kind of legs
yet well I'm each other that's one
reason the tea ready tends to go down as
an economy develops but then it goes
back up and those countries have very
well advanced IP systems right great
questions I tell you what yeah okay
let's do it go ahead that's just look at
one point is for a big business in China
over 10 years ago choice very Pablo to
copy ideas from us to Chinese yourself
or even today was killed and Chinese
skin to that but not as often as 10
years ago as a contrast actually China
has already clear develop so much
advanced in mobile internet or even
payment or something like that and now
there is even US companies are trying to
look at Chinese companies to see what
they can copy like I know that in
Twitter they look at how Chinese rule
how they manage their micro blog and
they try to copy some model too yes well
maybe facebook Messenger
or something even so I am here sorry my
tokin be enough and part of tea tea
party or tea whatever them and I'm
cooking I'm cooking one teacher from we
chat to us so that's this is how a lot
of international business is done so you
know one value in looking
internationally is to have the idea of
what new opportunities are thanks
everybody we've got some refreshments
outside and i'll be happy to talk to
people outside in a more informal
setting thanks
you